MALE SPEAKER: Welcome
back to the Googleplex,
and a new release of
Google Play Services.
That means new,
cool stuff that you
can use to build better apps.
Let's go inside
and check it out.
ROBOT: Stop right
there before you start.
Fix your deprecation.
MALE SPEAKER: What do you
mean fix my deprecation?
ROBOT: Deprecated logo.
Identity matters.
MALE SPEAKER: Gee, thanks.
ROBOT: That's better.
[WINDCHIMES]
MALE SPEAKER: The
new Google logo.
ROBOT: Thank you.
Proceed.
MALE SPEAKER: All right!
[WINDCHIMES]
A big part of this release
is about handling your user's
identity, because we've made
significant changes to the sign
in with Google API that
will simplify your code
and also improve
the user experience.
First off, the new
Google branding
is reflected in the button.
With a new sign in
API, you can get one
of these two standard buttons.
All updated, with a
new nice looking logo.
It's even possible
to create buttons
with your own
customized look and feel
as long as you follow the
branding guidelines located
here.
And that's not the
only improvements
visible to the user.
Prior to this release,
when the user pressed
the Sign In button,
they would potentially
have several steps to follow.
For example,
selecting an account,
potentially creating
a new profile,
and needing to grant even the
most basic of permissions.
A not so great user experience.
So I'm happy to say
that we have now
streamlined this experience.
And with the new
sign in API, the user
only need to complete a single
step for basic profile access.
Just selecting their account.
And that's a really, really
great user experience.
But you get even more
with this new API
since it also
simplifies your code.
Before, the sign in process
was tightly entangled
with the Google API
client connectivity flow,
making the code to connect
multiple APIs difficult.
But now they have
been separated,
leading to much simplified code.
So why is this helpful?
Well, if your app
adds additional scopes
or connect APIs
dynamically then you
don't need to write code
to reconnect the Google API
client.
Also, the new sign in
flow has better support
to manage recoverable errors.
So you don't have to write as
much code to deal with that.
And that's great.
I mean, less code
means less complexity.
[DING] Perhaps.
Well, [HORN] not necessarily.
But less code is better for
you [DING] most of the time.
I think.
So anyway, there you have it.
The new sign in API
making life easier
for you, and the experience
better for your users.
And there is also some updates
for Fused Location Provider
API.
You know the technology in
Google Play Services that
combines multiple things
like GPS, cell towers,
as well as Wi-Fi to
identify your position as
accurately as possible.
When in this release,
we've added methods
to defuse location provider API.
With previous
releases it was not
possible to get the batch
location if you decided
to turn location updates off.
But that limitation
is now history
with the new flush
location method.
And we also have announcements
for the app invites API.
You know the one that allows
your users to invite and engage
their friends with your app.
In this release we've added
the get invitation method.
This method will set
up a result callback
that you can use to launch
your deep link activity.
This dramatically
simplifies your code,
so check out the
samples in the end.
And last but not least, we have
updates for the wearable data
API where you can now specify
a sync priority for data items.
So if you have something that
is really, really important
to sync as quickly
as possible, then you
should check this API out.
And that's it for this release
of Google Play Services,
but be sure to check out
these resources as well.
Now it's your turn to build
better apps with Google Play
Services.
So go out there and
create some great apps.
And don't forget to
tell us all about it.